hey did the cool did the right hey look
back in they pick it back up what I get
a Sunday okay okay okay
welcome welcome to another episode of
the thing the thing which being is the
Tiger belly which aka is the ship in
which I am the captain of in which I
have mates in which the my mates are
weak in their cowards
only would not survive in a
post-apocalyptic environment oh and I
got weak spineless piece of [ __ ] George
in the corner just one of the weakest of
whites
well let me say something right now hey
you guys if you guys were the pioneers
of this [ __ ] you guys would have died
off the Indians would have won your type
if you're top of white came to this
country we would not be America use a
pillow would still be uh yeah that's
weed
you got your a little stronger cousin
here Bryce bigger dick better looking
better than you in every way you conform
but it's fine because you're still a
human being okay we still have George
Gilbert right we are Gilbert a lot of
people forget about Ringo in the Beatles
that's true the rainbow you're the Ringo
of the [ __ ] thing alright so you know
George best
Ringo I don't know okay you know either
or are we call John yeah for sure babe I
mean and I will be I'll be John yeah
I'll be poppy Yoko yeah yeah you yeah
you'll be John your job yeah yeah can I
talk yeah
Oh bro starting out you that to count
down together you're gonna hear that
whole techno beat again that oh we love
this FYI
I'm doing that a whole thing exactly
what I just did from beginning to end
okay so ready go five four three two
what welcome to what is the thing we got
a wee quiet right now all right weakest
of all white man this guy used to get
[ __ ] pumped with Indian come oh no
man when you guys came here so you're
the ones that they bent over and put
[ __ ] strewed comes to Ryan you got
your weak cousin but better than your
right
this one right here who's got a [ __ ]
thick one and he's blowing your [ __ ]
[ __ ] apart
huh we got right here George Ringo why
we got a rare very special guest you
know uh about a couple years ago I don't
know a year and a half ago um I was on a
show called what would Diplo do it was
on the Vice lands mm-hmm was on the bias
lands and it was me G and sander big um
and I met this guy so I you know I don't
know who anyone is or whatever you don't
I don't but I you know so I don't
googling much so I show up right I think
was a table read or something right and
I see Dillon Francis but I'm like I have
thought you were like a guy from The
Groundlings because I got this guy's
really funny and wow this is like he was
a DJ yeah why got cut yeah I mean I go
this guy's a real comedic guy is funny
right yeah we do the tapering up this
guy I don't know where they got this guy
but this guy is legitimately funny right
and then they were like no he's like
like as big I go in won't wait and they
go hey Jay I got one oh my god but he
can do comedy - it's unfair it's [ __ ]
unfair and then we became kind of
friends right we were like that [ __ ]
around on set a lot and that began to
enjoy you and I call you a CW you know
what that means
I don't know boertie but I thought you
were gonna like at least be like it hi
Dylan and then I would talk yeah hi yeah
I remember CW and and yeah yeah but did
you would you I mean I don't be
narcissistic but um no did we have a
good you think you had a good bond or
Vyborg yeah well well um funny enough
you know I grew up on MADtv so I've
always been a massive fan and when when
Brandon Dermer was like we're gonna try
to get Bobby to play Kevin I was like oh
my god that's the best thing ever call a
while Kevin's my manager also a funny
thing about the show is that he manages
you - yeah oh the plot thickens
yeah I think so thick it's so [ __ ]
funny because um so I play his manager
so anyway this this you manage me now
just grew very much can I call him go
that's correct yeah this half cook he's
half right till I tell us if he's a half
[ __ ] say I know you're smart why
[Music]